[Musique]
bonjour c'est maria deva de harkeev
ukraine aujourd'hui c'est le 20 mars et le
25e jour de la guerre russe contre l'ukraine
experte en sécurité dans ce
magazine d'information
je suis devant l'
immeuble résidentiel qui a été chauffé hier par un
missile russe utilisé par la russie
des bombes à sous-munitions ici à kharkiv
détruisant des zones résidentielles et le
centre historique
ce que vous voyez derrière moi
médias d'état russes et chaînes de propagande toutes
les opérations militaires spéciales
ils ont nié le fait de la guerre en ukraine
combattre la condamnation des
victimes
acceptées
je faisais des recherches sur la désinformation russe
depuis que cette guerre a réellement commencé  en 2014
parce que ce qui se passe maintenant c'est que la
russie réinvente l'ukraine à une nouvelle
échelle mais nous sommes en état de guerre
depuis 2014 quand la russie a déjà annexé la
crimée et occupée ne passe pas donc je
pense que je suis dans cette guerre de l'information
essayant de me battre  avec la
désinformation russe et a décidé qu'il est
très important de rester à kharkiv et de
montrer la situation réelle  ion parce qu'il
y a très peu de journalistes internationaux et
j'ai vu que cette information est
importante et en faisant cela en fournissant
la vraie information et en combattant la
euh la désinformation provenant des
médias d'État russes j'aide l'ukraine à se battre
sur ce champ de bataille et
je me bats sur le champ de bataille de l'information  quand
euh les
unités de défense territoriale militaires et défensives combattent
sur le terrain,
j'ai vu que le public le plus international
suivait la situation en
ukraine sur twitter donc j'avais un compte
mais ce n'était pas vraiment actif mais à ce
moment j'ai décidé que je devais  mettre plus
sur twitter pour que les gens du
monde entier puissent voir ce qui se
passe alors j'ai commencé à faire des vidéos
tous les jours de la destruction massive et des
bâtiments qui ont été bombardés et
bombardés
ce jour par la russie parce que la russie
prétend constamment que ce n'est pas le cas  obus
et ne cible pas les zones résidentielles
et je vois de ma fenêtre qu'ils
sont ciblés quotidiennement avant la guerre  il n'y
avait probablement pas plus de 300
abonnés sur le compte twitter et maintenant
c'est plus de 65 000 et certaines vidéos
ont dépassé le million de
vues
objectifs la
plupart de la désinformation est destinée
à un public éternel russe car
en ukraine l'ukraine est très résistante à
ce genre de désinformation  même c'est en
russe, donc personne ici ne croit en cela
euh depuis 2014, nous l'avons vu beaucoup, alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils ciblent le plus euh les russes
eux-mêmes et ils créent cette
autre réalité d'information complète pour les gens
en Russie dans cette réalité qu'ils ont
créée il y a
ils ne tuent pas de civils ils ne tuent pas de
femmes ils ne bombardent pas les
villes ukrainiennes ils prétendent que les ukrainiens le
font eux-mêmes donc c'est très populaire
donc pour nous cela semble incroyable mais les gens
en russie croient en ce
nombre
ce qui se passe c'est que le télégramme est
extrêmement populaire en ukraine et ces
groupes dans le télégramme que très souvent ce
sont des animaux donc vous ne savez pas qui est
derrière ces gro  ups et donc ce qui se passe
très souvent, c'est qu'une sorte de
certains de ces comptes publiera des
séquences vidéo avec une description et des actifs que vous connaissez,
il est très populaire que les
gens commencent à partager cette
information,
certaines séquences n'étaient pas pertinentes pour le
dicton réel sous  ce message,
mais
je suppose que cela pourrait être fait
exprès, donc ce que la russie doit maintenant faire,
c'est que la
russie voit que l'ukraine gagne dans
cette guerre de l'information, évidemment parce que la
position ukrainienne est entendue partout
et que tout le monde soutient l'ukraine et
que ferait la russie  faire est-ce qu'il va essayer de
diminuer et vous savez diminuer ce
soutien et comment pouvez-vous faire en
sorte que cela se produise, vous devriez savoir demander
et
euh et poser la question tout ce
qui est fourni par l'ukraine alors comme faire
douter les gens de l'ukrainien euh  comme des
informations provenant d'ukraine et
c'est
un scénario très possible pour mettre de la
désinformation que vous connaissez dans certaines
chaînes de télégrammes anonymes qui seront pic  ked plus
tard et ensuite vous pouvez venir et dire que
ce sont de fausses informations, sachez-le,
regardez-le et probablement l'ukraine est-ce
que vous savez
que vous utilisez cela exprès,
je suppose que l'ukraine tiendra
parce que ce que nous voyons maintenant est un très bon
la position que l'ukraine a et déjà
trop de temps s'est écoulé et si la russie avait la
moindre capacité de
faire ce qu'elle avait prévu de faire, elle l'
a déjà fait, alors maintenant
elle continuera à amener de nouvelles troupes maintenant
elle poussera sur la biélorussie  être de faire venir
les troupes de biller nous disons et
j'espère vraiment une sorte de
résolution diplomatique euh parce que nous savons
que les pourparlers sont en cours et il y
a déjà eu quatre séries de ces
pourparlers et j'espère que l'ukraine sera
maintenant dans ces pourparlers sur aucune position forte
parce que nous nous défendons et
nous ne sommes pas en position de faiblesse et
cela permettra un cessez-le-feu parce
que ce que je ne veux pas voir, c'est plus de pertes
parmi euh mes compatriotes  ong ukrainiens
donc c'est ce que les gens attendent ici
alors pour arrêter ce bombardement et arrêter
ce bombardement
très intéressant
merci beaucoup